hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the new Sony a 6400 this
was just announced by Sony and we're
getting a chance to check it out early
this is due out in February so if you're
watching this video and this camera is
already out I'll put some links in the
description where you can check out some
future videos that I'll be making with
this camera this is a huge upgrade from
the a 6300 and a small upgrade from the
a 6500 which has been my go-to
recommended vlogging camera for the past
few years so we have that camera right
here this thing has been on so many
adventures it's been around the world
and it has been such an incredible
camera so judging by body styles the
6500 and the 6400 look very very similar
but there was one huge factor that the
6400 has that the 6500 does not have is
a flip screen I know this is something
that we have been begging Sony to do in
any of their full-frame or mirrorless
options a lot of the times you can't see
what you're filming and most of us we're
always filming ourselves if we're
filming on the go I don't but so many
times in hotels that I forgot my little
monitor and I'll have to film a video
and just hope that I'm in frame the only
way that I can kind of see you guys is
there's a mirror go like this to see in
the mirror to see you it's really quite
silly this is such an exciting exciting
thing that I think a lot of you guys are
really really gonna love pearls in my
video this past year I did upgrade to
the a7 3 which is an incredible camera
so that camera has been pretty much my
main camera when I'm out and about that
wasn't good maybe I just don't like this
club it's just not sized right for my
body
[Music]
for these videos that I film like this
these are all filmed on the a7s2
now this isn't a full-frame camera like
a 7-3 but it is the latest generation
aps-c mirrorless in the sony alpha
family look at that you guys can see
yourself this is so great I'm so glad
they finally decided to add a flip
screen so this baffle up screen is an
entirely new to Sony they have the rx100
mark 5 as you can see here it has a very
similar style so they basically just
replicated what they did on the rx100
and attach that to the 6400 one of the
challenges with this is if you have an
external microphone you won't be able to
see the screen if you use it so this is
my normal setup you just have a
microphone that attaches to here this is
one of my favorite microphones because
it does work with Sony's hotshoe so you
don't need to use any plugs or anything
it just automatically works so as you
can see that's gonna pose a bit of a
problem but the good thing is when I am
filming I can still see if I'm in frame
or in focus even though that microphone
is in the way one of the good things
though is these cameras have really good
onboard audio so I did a text with the
microphone without the microphone and
you can see there is a difference but
it's definitely not something that is
necessary in every condition setup that
I'm currently using this is a little bit
not really the most practical because I
can't actually see myself too well but I
can see enough to know if I'm in a frame
or not this is a very simple setup this
is usually my go-to even though I can't
fully see the screen it still works
[Music]
so I popped off the microphone to see
what the onboard audio sounds like and
this is what it sounds like in
comparison to using this microphone that
was on that face oh my gosh I love this
lip up screen so much it's just like
finally you've arrived
if you are outside or you're worried
think there's gonna be wind I would
recommend using a microphone we also put
together a few vlogging rig options so
if you do want to add an external mic
and still be able to see your screen
this is something that I will probably
be using pretty frequently especially
when I travel and honestly I cannot
recommend this microphone enough because
it will also work with a hot shoe but it
also comes with a cable so if you do
decide to use this setup you can just
plug the microphone in directly to the
audio input so this is my current setup
I have this I belted bracket this does
make the camera a little bit bigger but
you're gonna have better audio you're
still gonna be able to see your screen
up here and Jenna also has a very
interesting setup she's got the flip up
screen and this is kind of a side option
which I actually really like this too
because I feel like I love being able to
hold my camera from the bottom I like
both options it's gonna be interesting
to see what you guys end up doing I have
this bad habit already of looking up at
the screen instead of looking here
reminder to you guys don't look at the
screen look at the lens but you can look
at the screen when like you know you're
not filming anything one of the main
highlights and probably most of you guys
are wondering how much does this thing
cost you might also be wondering why do
you have tape all over it I have it
taped because this camera isn't
officially out yet so I didn't want
people to know what I was filming with
the price for just the body is $900
which is actually really good because
the price of this Sony rx100 is almost
like a thousand maybe even over a
thousand if you get some of the other
packages so not only are you getting an
incredible camera but you're getting the
option to have interchangeable lenses
which is huge because you can change the
look of your videos so easily by
switching out lenses obviously that's
not new information to most of you but
for some of you it may be with the 16 to
50 millimeter lens that'll run you
$1,100 and with this current rig that I
have on right now this will run you
1,300 and this is the 18 to 135
millimeter lens I really like this lens
it's great it's super versatile and even
though it is an 18 millimeter it'll
probably act as about a 24 millimeter
when you're holding it out filming
yourself it's just the right length to
fit yourself in frame and yet
zoom options to be able to get up and
close to get really cool close-up shots
of b-roll
[Music]
not autofocus Chris Bay this is my first
test of the a 6400 I'm using a super
simple setup right now no microphone no
nothing just the simple 18-135 lens here
it is there's Jenna hi I'm 35 18
[Music]
remove the lens we just caught a little
pancake because that's basically what it
looks like it's so cute and so small so
if you are looking to save some money
but still want to get a fairly decent
lens I would definitely recommend this
it gets the job done it also makes your
camera super super light this is so
light like I can't believe it I'm so
used to vlogging only a 7-3 for the past
year this is just so magical another
really cool thing is this does interval
shooting for time lapses which is huge
so you'll be able to create 4k time
lapses you could shoot a JPEG and RAW so
depending upon what quality you're
looking for and you can make the choice
or you can shoot with both the intervals
can be set anywhere from 1 to 60 seconds
and you can shoot from 1 to 9999 shots
most of the new cameras that Sony has
been releasing if they've removed the
PlayMemories app from the camera so we
used to use that a lot to do time-lapse
videos and photos and all kinds of
things then now that option isn't
available being able to have built-in
interval shooting is incredible so you
will shortly be releasing some software
so it'll make it super easy to put those
together on your phone or on your
computer but you can just use final cut
or premiere or if you guys have a time
lapse app already that does it for you
you can use that this now has an smq
option which is right here on the wheel
this is something that most of the
higher end cameras have and that stands
for slow and quick this allows you to
easily create slow-mo videos this was
available on the previous version of the
6500 but it wasn't here on the menu dial
like this this is something that I use
so often on my a 7-3 so it's really
great to be able to just flip that
switch go to the s and Q and on this
camera you can film 120 frames a second
in slo-mo and another little trick that
I like to do is if you turn the frame
rate to 1 that'll also allow you to do
time-lapse videos obviously the
time-lapse video on the s and Q setting
isn't as good as if you do the interval
shooting because you're getting those
high res photos can tell the quality
difference so this one was shot on
interval shooting
[Music]
and this was shot on one frame a second
the s and Q option the seq option is
super easy super simple it basically
makes the video for you so you don't
have to do any post-production but if
you do want that higher quality video I
definitely recommend trying out the
interval shooting this will shoot 4k 30
frames a second and also 24 frames so I
would love to hear a show of hands who
likes xxx and who likes 24 leave those
in the comments below as I said you can
also shoot Full HD in 120 frames a
second also 60 frames a second it can
also do 4k HDR hlg it also has a support
for s log 2 and s log 3 so if you are
looking to color great some of your
footage that is something that this will
be able to provide you with as you can
see here this is what it looks like
normally and this is what it looks like
color graded a little bit in Final Cut
something else that is new in this
camera is you can do proxy recording so
most of my videos I shoot in 4k and I
just take those 4k clips and I edit
those directly on my computer but if you
do have a slower machine or if you're
having someone else edit your videos you
can send them the proxy files but what's
great is you won't have to render those
out from your original 4k clips this
will automatically save those for you
they shoot a lot of my videos myself so
being able to have a super fast
autofocus is so important so one of the
things that I do like is this camera
does have a touchscreen you can turn
that on or you can turn that off this is
also good if you're just out and about
shooting because you're able to touch
track so as you can see here this is an
option of tracking my sister it is doing
some really great face tracking so even
as she's stepping behind things and
hiding as soon as she reappears it
automatically picks up her face this is
also great if I'm vlogging as well
because I'm able to keep my face and
focus so as you can see right now the
face tracking is happening I'm filming
my camera filming myself don't think
I'm filming you filming generally
filming this is so absurd but there's a
lot going into making this video trying
to get you guys these shots but there's
also eye tracking so when you go in to
take photos you'll be able to choose the
left or the right eye or have it set up
that it will Auto determine which I
should be in focus so we're gonna test
that out now with Jenna this is
incredible because you always want the
eye to be in focus now the iaf only
works when you're taking photos but this
is so great for when you're taking
portrait shots I was testing out this
lens this lens it basically cost more
through this entire camera setup but
this is the 1.4 24 millimeter G master
lens and Sony let me borrow this to test
out so that's one of the really great
things is if you do have this body you
can upgrade and get different lenses
this is a full frame lens and it still
will work on this so that's definitely
great news if you do have any of the
lenses but Jenna and I were at dinner
and I was taking some gorgeous shots of
her while she waited for her pasta oh
probably one of the most exciting things
that I almost forgot about is this
doesn't have the 29 minute limit you
guys this is huge because all of these
other Sony cameras they end up cutting
it 29 minutes but this extends that
limit there's a lot of factors that go
into play as to how long this will
record yes it will record along with in
29 minutes but if you don't have an SD
card that can hold more than 29 minutes
for your SD card is full or it's really
hot in the room your camera may overheat
and then shut off which is a good thing
because that's preserving your camera
but there is an option that you can go
in and turn that off so camera will stay
recording even if it is at a higher
temperature day two of vlogging with the
a 6400 we are going to breakfast
some riveting content so today we're in
Point Dume this is one of our favorite
places to come out in a film because
it's so beautiful and there's so much
different things that you can film but
it's I decided she used 18 to 135 lens I
feel like this is probably my go-to lens
you're able to still film yourself we're
heading up this hill I have so much
stuff in my backpack I think I'm gonna
pass out but I'm actually gonna
[Music]
it's so crazy because we almost always
have perfect weather in Los Angeles
right now it's freezing it's overcast
and not sunny at all we've been trying
to get some cool shots for you guys but
the weather just hasn't been cooperating
the battery life on the older Sony
cameras like the a7s2 these 6500 the
6300 and the 6400 they all use this same
batteries and it's not new information
but these batteries do not last very
long at all that was one of the biggest
hurdles that I used to have with the
a7s2 because I would do kitchen shoots
and we would be filming all day long so
one of the things that I got for that
especially now that this doesn't cut it
29 minutes I got one of the AC adapters
so it's basically just this but it has a
cord plugs into where the battery goes
and then that cord plugs into the wall
it's actually what I'm using right now
on this camera setup I did notice the
battery life does seem to be a little
bit better than the a 6500 but it still
is along those same lines because it is
the same battery for comparison this is
the battery that is in a 7 3 and a 7 3
battery life is absolutely incredible
obviously it's better because the
battery is massive it is so much bigger
than this one so you're obviously able
to get much better battery life out of
it so my recommendation to you if you do
have the a7 s2 or they 6500 or you do
plan on upgrading to the 6,400 get
yourself some extra batteries or they
also have some different battery
converter options so there's this one
that I saw which I didn't even know they
had this you can attach four of these
batteries to your camera using kind of
that same setup that I talked about for
one thing that's kind of neat that I
really never used before but you could
do this in the a 6500 as well but it's
pretty nice feature if you're filming
and wanna grab a stool for a thumbnail
later you can capture still photos from
video it'll capture 8 megapixel photos
from a 4k video and 4 mega pixel from an
HD clip so now I want to take you guys
through a vlog setup so let me show you
what I mostly have been using with this
camera I love this little tripod mount
it's perfect if you want to use it as a
tripod or you can hold it out like
for vlogging if you do want to add on a
microphone this is honestly the easiest
way to do it yes your screen is gonna be
obstructed this is the easiest way to go
but if you do want to be able to see
your screen which is definitely the main
point of this camera my sister came up
with this rig which I really liked
so using the same tripod this little
mount plate screws on just like that I
like leaving enough room on the side
here so that you're able to pop the
battery out this little mounting plate
will just attach right to here add
different microphones or if you want to
get really wild this shotgun microphone
is ridiculous and guess what
you guys are ready for vlogging although
you're gonna to be careful because the
microphone keeps getting in this shot
this is a little aggressive I don't
think that this is an ideal setup for
vlogging but if you want really good
audio this is something that you'll need
so another option obviously this is
extremely aggressive I'm always so
concerned about audio so it's something
that I always experiment quite often
with this is one of Sony's XLR mouths
this is actually what I use all the time
when I'm filming my videos this has a
little hotshoe so this plugs in directly
right into your camera and this gives
you two XLR options right here right so
now we're getting a little silly
these are Sennheiser AVX wireless
microphones these are my favorite mostly
because they automatically scan for
channels to make sure that you don't
have any distortion or anything and it's
great because you can move this around
depending upon what your setup looks
like you can move that from side to side
it's also small and compact and they're
really really great so I've been using
these probably the past year so I look
absurd and this is something I think
that if you were filming it with a crew
or I don't know you'd make your friends
hold this because this is kind of crazy
actually I feel like I can add some
other things onto this you're now ready
for a future film I mean oh boy
my gosh he also don't need the tripod
can you also have this little side mount
but I do prefer holding his on the
bottom like this because it will keep
your arm at the bottom as opposed to off
to the side when you're vlogging one
thing to note on this XLR adapter is
there are two different versions so
there's one you're seeing here that has
this cable with the hotshoe attached but
one that I'm using here than filming
this video on in front of me does not
have this cable and the hotshoe is
attached directly to here so this cable
is non-existent for most situations the
one that I'm filming with right here is
probably the best option because that
doesn't give you this cable but first
setup like this where you do want to
have the microphone off to the side this
is perfect for this sort of situation so
honestly you're gonna have to ask
yourself like what am I going to be
doing what do I actually need is this
overkill potentially but I've been
creating a lot of videos for a really
long time and the type of stuff that I
do this is the things that I need but
for someone just starting out honestly
all you need is a camera you can use
your phone to start so that my friends
was a first look at the brand new Sony a
6400 with the flip up screen this is
gonna be so great for vloggers because
this is honestly all you need this right
here this is a perfect setup if you need
a microphone pop this thing on I
probably would prefer a flip out screen
but I'm not going to be picky what
you're getting in these cameras is so
incredible that a lot of us have been
dealing without a flip screen for so
long because the camera is so so good
well thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you guys enjoy this video and you
got some insight into the new a 6400 by
Sony as I said at the beginning of this
video I will be updating the links in
the description so that if I have
created some videos about this camera
and it's already out and you're looking
for more information I will put those
all in the description and I look
forward to seeing what you guys think
but I'm gonna go and edit this video and
I will see you very very soon
[Music]